one of the things that viewers have been
asking me about has to do with languages
and what languages I know or use in my
work and how I acquired them and I think
there's kind of an interesting sort of
stories they're different stories for
different languages so I'm making this
video just to talk about languages I'm
not actually going to talk about how I
think people ought to learn languages
I'll talk a little bit about different
styles or approaches to it but I'll just
tell you about how how I ended up with
the languages that that I've got that I
use as research tools so obviously of
course I don't need to talk about
English because I'm a native speaker I'm
an American and grew up in Wisconsin and
you can hear my my accent which is
interesting way not from what linguists
tell us the same accent as people used
in this part of New York but that's a
whole different discussion so I'm going
to talk about each one of the the main
four languages that I use in my my work
as a philosopher that's French German
Latin and classical Greek and then I'll
talk a little bit about some of the
other languages I've dabbled with and
admittedly have made very very little
progress with
so French is a language that I started
out with very early on in part
advantaged because my family is actually
french-canadian
they've been here in the States for from
from my perspective five generations my
great-great-grandfather fought in the
American Civil War he crossed the border
to take the place of a doctor's son back
then you could hire somebody to take
your place if you got drafted or
conscripted and he ended up staying in
the United States up in New England and
our family name which was memories lost
a few of the letters because apparently
he couldn't he couldn't spell it or
somebody else wrote it down wrong and
they stayed in that area for quite a
while my grandfather's generation as
kids they ended up moving to Chicago and
growing up in Chicago but they grew up
back then chicago was divided into a
whole bunch of little ethnic districts
and they grew up in an ethnic district
that was largely french-canadian and
interestingly enough Menominee India and
the French Canadians and and various
Native American tribes have had
long-standing connections as a matter of
fact the City of Milwaukee was actually
founded by a french-canadian Menominee
Indian couple that is your nose who
started things off there so in any case
you would think that everybody would
have learned English but not all of them
did and all the way down to my mom's
generation French was spoken in the
house and my mom didn't learn English
even though she would have been at that
point a fourth-generation immigrant
until she went to elementary school and
the main reason she learned it was
because the Irish girls would pick on
her and you know she didn't know English
so I grew up in a household where like
it or not you you heard a lot of French
and my mom would speak French to me my
dad of course didn't didn't speak French
well he learned a little bit so he
couldn't he could
stand things but the older people and my
family was very you know closely
connected we spent a lot of time
together the older people would speak
French back and forth and I guess I just
sort of picked up some of it on the way
I also learned how to swear in French
really good for my my uncle so you know
things before I even know what they
meant like Cal yes and him exist you
know things like that
so it was kind of an interesting
situation I knew some French I didn't
usually speak French with my mom but she
would sometimes say things like you know
how long Zee and when we cross you know
a go past a graveyard we could say a
prayer in French you know bone she's in
visitor court and I assimilated some of
that but that's not yet learning a
language and she wanted me to know
French and she could see that the kids
in my generation were really not picking
up on the French and she thought it
would be a useful thing for me to have
so when I was in Middle School and then
when I was in high school she she made
me sign up for taking French classes and
of course the teachers expected a lot
for me because I was supposed to you
know have something on the wall and I
was kind of rebellious kid so I did just
enough work to get by didn't learn an
awful lot didn't apply myself and now
fast forward past my army time and into
college when I first got to college they
knew that I knew French so they were
doing this experimental program where
they would have these these Suites and
there'd be three rooms in the suite that
would be people who are supposed to be
learning the language and then one one
native speaker when they had a French
suite in a German suite and Spanish
suite and a Japanese suite so they threw
me into the French suite along with a
guy who I'm still friends with actually
two people who I'm I'm still friends
with 20 years later and we we had to
take French classes and I I admittedly
kind of screwed often in those classes
as well you know I could get by
without doing an awful lot of work and
that was kind of lazy but I did learn a
lot of a lot of useful stuff and I would
talk with our teacher Cecile who was
living with us and we'd also go out
drinking and things like that so you
know that that was kind of a spur for me
then after I graduated I decided it was
time to buckle down and actually learn
French
I took a year in between undergraduate
and graduate school and during that time
I really concentrated on languages in
part because I wanted to go to Europe
and travel around a bit so I buckled
down and I got myself some French
textbooks and I started working my way
through things and I actually started
learning about the tent structure that I
was supposed to learn about before and
you know I was finding it coming fairly
fairly easily had the facility for
languages and then it was time to start
start reading and so that's what I did I
started I have a few props here that I'm
going to show you I started reading bold
layer and and and trying to translate
the poems myself which is very
challenging this is a book I had very
early on it's it's deliberately written
in a fairly simple style kind of loosely
ecology you know this is the stranger
then once I then I went to Europe well
actually I went to come back first with
my friend Edie and then after that I
went to Europe and traveled around for a
while and stayed with friends and just
kept on improving my language bought a
lot of books and then I got out and and
came to graduate school down in southern
Illinois so I came to SIU with with a
good solid foundation in French and then
I started sitting in on graduate level
French classes just just for fun and
hanging out at the French table and
stuff like that and and so I did a lot
of talking in French and I also started
you know expanding my my tastes so like
this is one of the books that I bought
there dieter raja cliff at least a so
life and I still love the book now it's
a very funny book and eventually
up writing my dissertation on this guy
Maurice bloom dal this is lack Co 1893
this is what I worked from and I you
know I didn't use the English
translations if unless I needed to
because I had it this is pretty typical
look for a French book too by the way
not recent French books but but you know
a lot of older French books and you know
I started doing translation eventually
well actually fairly recently I
published a book of translations from
the 1930s Christian philosophy debates
in France documents that that I
uncovered here and there mostly at the
Notre Dame library I've got a video
about that that I can I can link to here
at this point too if you're interested
in that sort of thing
and you know I've just sort of kept up
with it I don't get a chance to speak
much French anymore and I don't hear
quite so well and that makes
comprehension a little bit difficult in
in speaking but I translate and I read
French the most recent thing that I
translated was a a piece by a French
scholar on you scandium for an
encyclopedia so that's that's French I
used to be actually very nationalistic
about about you know french-canadian
things but I kind of I'm not no longer
quite so quite so worked up about that
sort of thing
so now German was a language that I had
some exposure to when I was a kid
actually in elementary school one of the
one of the people who lived up the
street had been an exchange student in
Germany and she came to our classroom
when I was in 4th grade I think and
talked to us a little bit about about
her experience and taught us a little
bit of German and then in in in
elementary school and maybe I'll do a
video about this some other time
I was one of those gifted talented kids
but we lived out of the sticks and they
had no idea what to do with us so they
gradually just released the regular
classes and sent us off into the library
or you know some room or some corner by
ourselves and you know so if you're good
in English they send you have to go find
some books and do a project and and so I
started learning German I found one of
those teach yourself German books and
then kind of you know putts around they
remember at least learning the numbers
then I didn't do much with it for a very
long time and when I was in the Army I
was stationed in Germany so we had to
take this German language class you know
something very very rudimentary and I
got through it now you know I had talked
with with native Germans from time to
time but I didn't do very much with it
and then again once I got into college
really didn't do much with it either but
that year your that I took between
graduate and undergraduate I also
focused on unlearning German and the
story of that is kind of interesting
this is a very old teacher self German
book it's gonna layer a book der
deutschen Shiprock oh alright and what's
really cool about this book hold this up
so you can see is it teaches you not
just regular you know German stuff but
it teaches you this old script which is
called the frock tour which they don't
they don't teach very much anymore in
part because you know after World War 2
there was a lot of changes cultural
changes that
place and being able to read this old
script means that I can read older
German books that that some younger
German people can't can't actually read
unless they've learned the the frocked
or that's quite beautiful there were
some problems with you know I worked my
entire way through this this book and I
would do a lot of exercises and drills
and stuff like that one of the problems
with this is that I didn't learn a lot
of modern contemporary vocabulary so I
remember actually asking somebody on a
train
you know for an Veda literally a feather
but that was the old name for panelists
that I should have said you know kugel
Schreiber and then you know here and
there I would buy myself books when I
could find them this is Jakob Jakob
Grimm zu birdie Deutsche Shaka a lot of
people don't know that the Grimm
brothers were actually not just
interested in fairy tales they were
interested in fairy tales in part
because they were interested in the
German language and in preserving that
they were part of this this Romantic
movement and Grimm was actually a
linguist and these this is his you know
discussions again if you can't read the
old script this this book wouldn't be
very very useful I got into other things
as well I tried to I still haven't
gotten around to this but this is a this
is a little book that I bought I believe
in Milwaukee
it's Nibelungen north the story of the
Nibelungen with a middle high german
grammar so it's it's you know it's got
the the poems as you can see somebody
marked this up quite a bit and in the
back it actually has this entire
glossary and maybe it's in the front I
haven't looked at this for a long time
yeah it has a whole bunch of stuff in
German for teaching yourself middle high
german and so i used to try to work my
way through that i haven't done it for a
while here's here's another at this
point failed project i was at one time
trying to teach myself
anglo-saxon because it's it's fairly
close and again this is one of those
sort of books where he has the grammar
and the start and if you know ordinary
high german well then you can make some
progress with that so I don't do that
much with German these days I mean I
read it but I haven't gotten around to
you know these things it's a beautiful
language a lot of people give it a bad
rap but but it you know like French it's
a great language to have through
research there's tons and tons of
material out there that's not translated
that is great to be able to access on
the sort of things that I'm
understudying so if I want to study
Aristotle for example there's a lot of
material in French a lot of material in
German that just hasn't made its way
into English
Latin is a language that again I had
some exposure to when I was a kid but
really you know I screwed around didn't
if you'll work with it until I got into
graduate school so here's the story with
that when I was in what sixth and
seventh grade I went to a private middle
school and I'll tell the whole story
some other times very interesting but
but I don't want to get into those
details and one of the features of this
middle school was that in sixth and
seventh grade you had to learn Latin one
in Latin too so I remember learning not
an awful lot but you know a good bit you
know fer for a middle schooler we
learned a lot of vocabulary and we
learned you know at least the the first
and second declension I don't think we
learned the third declension and we
learned you know some some conjugations
and that sort of thing and I just sort
of let it slide and I remember you know
getting out my dad's old Latin textbooks
that he had when he was in high school
so I went to Catholic High School and
putzing around with them but I didn't do
too much with those either then when I
was in college really didn't do anything
of Latin either and I didn't really do
anything until I got to graduate school
and then I taught myself Latin and again
it's a kind of weird idiosyncratic story
you know I taught myself German out of
that teach yourself German book from
more than a century ago I taught myself
Latin using a Field Manual that was
written for army jag officers for them
to learn enough Latin to be able to I
don't know do something with it alright
and I worked my way through the entire
book I was very disciplined at the time
I said I'm gonna learn Latin and then
that took me about a semester and I
thought well same thing that I did with
French and same thing that I did with
German I need to start reading some
actual books you know some stories
something
so that I can actually you know develop
my vocabulary and this is the book that
I actually picked out this is Cicero's I
was reading the académica which is about
Plato's Academy and and and how it turns
of skepticism so I got myself this from
the not this actual copy but this this
book from our library and I've started
to try to work my way through it now
what's interesting about this this is a
Loeb Library Edition you can see that it
has the Latin on one side and the
English on the other side so it's kind
of good because if you get lost you can
actually like go to the English and see
what's going on and I underestimated how
difficult Cicero would be so after an
entire next semester of working about an
hour a day I'd only made 10 pages
properly it's the whole thing in part
because Cicero is a very very complex
author a lot of vocabulary and he writes
what are called Ciceronian periods where
you know you could in Latin you can have
these immense sets of clauses that are
all nested within each other because you
have you have case and you can you know
make all these references and it's very
beautiful and I can convey very complex
thoughts but it was very tough for me to
work my way through so I had to admit
defeat and I said wow I gotta I gotta
find myself some resources so I looked
at you know I went to the bookstore the
university bookstore and I said well
what are they actually using to learn
Latin and they were using this so this
wheel lock thing which I'm not super
impressed with it's not bad but it's
it's not you know isn't much better than
the Jag book that I had and they have
this this is Allan green O's Latin
grammar and it's a well it's it's four
hundred and ninety pages long it's very
dense and it covers just about
everything that you can find in Latin
grammar so I worked my way through this
entire book
treating it as a textbook going over it
bit by bit by bit and that took me about
another semester to do very intensive
work you know spending several hours a
day with it because I really wanted to
to learn Latin well it's great because
it gives you tons of examples the other
thing I really love about this grammar
is that the guys who worked on it we're
in two indo-european linguistics and
I'll talk a little bit more about why
that matters when I get to the Greek
stuff so I you know I worked my way
through that and then I thought well I
got to find some easier stuff to read so
what I did is I started with Thomas
Aquinas this is the Blackfriars
translation which again English on one
page Latin on the other page you can you
can get a whole set of volumes of these
is the summit's halo guy and I wasn't
getting any any good Thomas Aquinas in
my graduate program because they really
had no interest in studying him they
were doing analytic and confidential and
American philosophy for the most part
not a lot of history of philosophy so I
thought well I should I should read this
guy he's pretty important so I started
working my way through this limit a
alodia and III didn't get through the
entire thing of course but I started
reading it and then I got captivated by
it I'm not a Thomas but I'm a great
admirer of Thomas Aquinas in part
because once you actually can start
reading the stuff in Latin and you're
not dependent on these translations
which sometimes are very good but
sometimes are rather misleading a whole
world opens up to you and I started
reading Thomas and then after I'd read
some Thomas I thought well I need
something a bit more challenging I'm not
going to try to take on Cicero right now
or Augustine who would be kind of in the
middle and I found Saint Anselm and I
started reading him and there's a whole
story about how I became a st. Anselm
scholar that I'll tell us in another
another video so that I just kept up
with it I eventually became part of the
Thomas Aquinas translation project which
is run out of de Salle University and
worked on translate
some of Thomas's commentaries on the
Psalms and I've translated some other
things in Latin I'm working on a
translation of a work by by st. Anselm
called the the English translation would
be something like on similitudes
a similitude in abuse and I really enjoy
working with Latin it opens up like I
said in an whole entire world for you
when you actually have it some people
want to say oh it's a dead language
those are people who don't realize how
much is out there and how important
languages are also if you know Latin it
really helps you with with English
English grammar and vocabulary and all
that sort of stuff but even if you want
to read say Rene Descartes you know
Descartes wrote the meditations in Latin
then they were translated in French and
now we read them in English right so if
you want to see the original stuff you
want to read it in
now to Greek and with this one I
actually did things the way that people
generally ought to learn languages I
took classes in it and at Southern
Illinois University we had this guy Rick
Williams who was the head of the
classics department and also I believe
the head of the Honors Program at the
time he was a classicist great guy I
loved working with him
and I had a friend Gary who was was
studying Greek in parkas Gary who's
interested in Aristotle and Gary and I
used to argue about Nietzsche all the
time but in any case I Gary had studied
Greek through the the sequence and he
said it's gonna really open things up
for you and I already had French and
German and Latin oh I thought well you
know adding Greek to it would really
clinch things for me so I started taking
the the course sequence and we started
out with 12 people in the first class
Griet elementary Greek one I think it
was called and only four people made it
to the end of the semester because Greek
is pretty tough and you got to work your
your butt off in order to master these
things it's a language like Latin that
has case and you know moods are
important and you got to memorize a lot
of things so we started out with with 12
went to four we started out the next
semester with four and only two of us
finished and I was the only person who
went on and started doing readings after
that and I would do reading courses with
some of the other instructors so we
started out with fairly easy stuff we
read Plato's credo and some some
speeches you know fairly simple stuff
then we read some Lucien that that first
semester and then we started diving into
things like reading Herodotus which you
go learn a whole different vocabulary
and
homer again whole different vocabulary
and yeah it's got actually got its own
dictionary for reading homer and then I
started reading Plato and Aristotle in
earnest in in Greek you know I read the
symposium for an entire semester with
Rick Williams and I read Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics for an entire
semester with with another guy who I
don't remember
Johnson was his name he I don't think
he's there anymore
and again with with the Greek it's very
important to have a good Greek grammar
this is the Smyth this is the same sort
of deal as the Allen and Greene oh this
is the gold standard and this is big I
mean you know this one is very dense
book you know 700 odd pages and it goes
through everything that we know about
classic Greek grammar and I worked my
way again through this entire thing
thank God I did because I'm so busy
these days I don't have time to keep up
with all of this and the foundation that
I laid for myself is what I'm drawing on
now I don't I don't have the time to do
the intensive language study but this is
also based on indo-european linguistics
so you know when we talk about
indo-european linguistics we're thinking
about how the language is that you know
form these great families so the Celtic
languages the italic languages that
Latin comes from on the Romance
languages after that the you know
Hellenic Greek hit AI Sanskrit all these
these these language families Germanic
they all come from a common stem in
proto indo-european which then spreads
out into all these other language
families and then they split up even
more well if you know one major
indo-european language like German then
you go to start studying Greek you've
already prepared yourself for working
with cases or thinking about conjugation
it makes it a lot easier to learn it and
here's a bit of a digression when I was
studying Greek I realized that I tend to
learn languages differently
many other people when it comes to a
language a language is a very complex
interconnected system and it has all
sorts of what we call synchronic
connections and then diachronic
connections that reflect changes over
time and a lot of people like to look at
the little bits and memorize all the
little bits so they do you know what I
call paradigms and you know first do a
verb and go through all the persons and
numbers for the present present
indicative and the imperfect and the
heiress then the future then bla bla bla
right
memorize the you know principal parts of
the verbs I wanted to know the answers
well why is this like that I wanted to
know what the rules were and you know
when you're studying a language there
seem to be all these sort of
irregularities well no those are
actually rule governed - it's just that
you've got a whole bunch of different
rules imposing on each other and
modifying each other and changing their
result slightly here and there and there
and what was great about the
indo-european grammar part was they had
answers to the why for me so if I
learned that I didn't need to
necessarily memorize the way that other
people did I could deduce and derive and
it was it was you know at that point in
my life it was really something that I
found very fruitful and very exciting in
a learning where did these stems all
come from and why does this play out
this way why does you know why is this
error system of verbs over here why do
they have these these endings
I found that stuff fascinating another
thing that you need if you're if you're
going to study languages of course
lexicons or dictionaries this is what we
call the the little little the little
and Scott it comes in a little and a
medium and a large and the largest you
know a giant book and the middle is okay
the
the little one is is pretty good it's
got a lot of references and it gives you
the English for a lot of a lot of the
Greek things you're going to come across
you have to know how to derive the Greek
words because case and conjugation play
a declension and conjugation play major
roles in the Greek of course this is a
different lexicon this is a New
Testament lexicon and classical Greek it
includes more than one language strictly
speaking you have different dialects so
Homer is a different dialect than Plato
is and what we call Koine the Greek that
was spoken by people in New Testament
times is a Greek New Testament so you
can see like this is the letter to the
Romans but also the miles it's all in
Greek and the Greek that Paul is writing
or the Greek that you know Luke and kata
Luke Ione is writing is a somewhat
different Greek than the Greek that
Plato was writing or somebody like like
Lucian is writing interestingly enough
well here's another Loeb Edition this is
Epictetus and again Greek on one side
English on the other very handy
Epictetus is actually writing something
that's kind of closer to coin a in some
respects than - it's a classic attic
Greek Aristotle already you can see some
with certain verbs of the transition
that's going on
leading to 20 now I I do quite a bit of
reading in Greek still in part because
once you can read the stuff in Greek it
opens up like I said an entirely new
vistas for you you start seeing
connections between things the book that
I'm writing on Aristotle and anger would
not be possible if I couldn't read
Aristotle and Greek and see that the
same stuff is being talked about in this
work over here
as is being talked about in this work
over here but it's getting translated
differently here than it is here because
different people are focusing on these
sorts
of things so I really enjoy working with
Greek and I haven't translated anything
yet I may you never know but I'm content
to to just provide the translations in
the Articles that I write on Aristotle
and eventually on Epictetus
there are a few other languages that I
have I would just say bust around with
and I haven't learned an awful lot or
what I have learned I've managed to
forget to my chagrin and a lot of those
just been a product of my own laziness
because you know like I said I I have a
facility for languages so when I
actually do buckle down I can I can
learn quite a bit I've been to Portugal
and I learned a bit a bit of Portuguese
you know I bought some Portuguese books
and really haven't gotten around to
consolidating anything you know I can
actually like I can I can read this
stuff out loud but you know como a
philosophy a this that re de otra vez
vicious na primavera or Vento an orator
you know but the comprehension is a
whole different matter
I'm able to make some sense out of the
Romance language things on the basis of
the French and the the Latin that I am
surprisingly enough so I can I can hear
sometimes people speaking in Spanish and
understand what they're saying I can
read some Italian some Spanish and then
puzzle it out if it's not too jargony
or too rich or anything like that
Portuguese is a beautiful language and
in a lot of respects that sounds less
like Spanish and more like French it's
got a lot of siblings in it you know she
sounds like that and if I have the time
I would love to actually learn it you
know my one of my big goals is
eventually to read the Portuguese
national epic Osia Lucia - in Portuguese
but that may have to wait for a while
that's that's one of the things on my
bucket list what else I tried to teach
myself Italian and didn't get very far
with it unfortunately that's a pretty
complex language particularly and it's
it's a verb structure so that would have
taken some time I can puzzle out enough
to be able to read articles on you know
the Christian philosophy debates or on
the ants all
things like that but I can't really like
sit down with an Italian book and you
know like I couldn't read Dante for
example or even sit down with with you
know an Italian newspaper and figure out
what I'm reading the other main language
that I have dabbled with and really
ashamed to say I haven't done much with
his Chinese and Mandarin specifically I
took a Chinese class an intensive what
we call winterim class or it was you
know one month three hours a day and I
learned quite a bit in that and I still
have the the the reader that we used for
that but I didn't follow through with it
and I you know I know enough to say you
know wash Yug again don't when I speak a
little bit of Chinese but then after
that people start talking at me and I'm
like well who's it down yeah I don't
know what you're saying and I can order
two things that a Chinese restaurant I
can ask for water and you know I'd like
the chicken or things like that but but
I really can't do what I want to be able
to do with it
and it's a real shame because you know
if I had to pick three languages that I
think are most important for for kids to
be learning right now I would say
Spanish Mandarin and possibly Arabic so
you know Mandarin is a great language to
him I used to have more facility with it
I never learned that many characters in
part because I again I didn't apply
myself as I want to have trying to see
if I can find my little thing I copied
all these these Chinese proverbs into a
notebook which then I I studied over
some time as well but I didn't follow
through with it and it's really a shame
because I used to tutor Chinese students
so I had I had people that I learned
quite a bit from but I could have really
learned
more so you know maybe down the line
I'll actually learn Chinese as I ought
to it would be a very useful language to
have some facility with they have a
great Chinese philosophical tradition
that goes back you know just as far as
the Greek philosophical tradition the
Western philosophical tradition it'd be
lovely to be able to read it there's a
few other languages I wish I had you
know I would love to be able to read
Hebrew it would be great to know Russian
so I could read you know Dostoevsky and
social myths in and people like that in
the original but you know when you come
down to it then you've only got so much
time and when you learn a language it's
it's not like you learn it and then
there's a chip in your head that stays
there and it's always active you have to
keep working with it or else you start
it gradually starts to disappear and you
want to keep working and working and
working on it and that takes away time
that you could be spending learning new
languages so really you you have to pick
and choose what you're going to work
with for Western philosophy I would say
that of course you know the big five are
English French German Latin and
classical Greek it would be really nice
to have Italian along with that but that
usually doesn't doesn't figure in for
most people having five is is is enough
for for me I think I can't make any
claims to be you know it's super high
expert level but I can usually muddle
through and that's that's what I need
from my kind of work and yeah I think
that's probably enough about languages